let me bring up ellie'skovsky
and his warnings to uh to human
civilization that AI will likely kill
all of us uh what are your thoughts
about his perspective on this can you
still man his case
and uh what aspects would it do you
disagree
one thing that I find concerning in the
discussion of his arguments that um many
people are dismissive of his arguments
but they counter arguments that they're
giving are not very convincing to me
and So based on this date of discussion
I find that From elieza's perspective
and I think I can take that perspective
to some approximate degree that probably
is normally at his intellectual level
but it's uh I think I see what he's up
to and why he feels the way he does and
it makes total sense
I think that his perspective is somewhat
similar to the perspective of Ted
Kaczynski the infamous una bomber and
not that elieza would be willing to send
pipe bombs to anybody to blow them up
but when he wrote this Times article in
which he warned about AI being likely to
kill everybody and that we would need to
stop its development or halt it I think
there is a risk that he's taking that
somebody might get violent if they read
this and get really really scared
right so I think that there is some
consideration that he's making where
he's already going in this direction
where he has to take responsibility if
something happens and people get harmed
and the reason why Ted Kaczynski did
this was that from his own perspective
technological Society cannot be made
sustainable it's doomed to fail it's
going to lead to an environmental and
eventually also a human Holocaust in
which we die because of the
environmental destruction the
destruction of our food chains the
pollution of the environment and so From
kashinski's perspective we need to stop
industrialization we need to stop
technology we need to go back because he
didn't see a way moving forward right
and I suspect that in some sense there's
a similarity in early years thinking uh
through to this kind of fear about
progress
and I'm not dismissive about this at all
I take it quite seriously and I think
that there is a chance that could happen
that if we build machines that get
control over processes
um that are crucial for the regulation
of life on Earth and we no longer have
agency to influence what's happening
there that this might create large-scale
disasters for us do you have a sense
that the the March towards this
uncontrollable autonomy a super
intelligence systems is
inevitable
that there's no I mean that's
essentially what he's saying that
there's no hope his advice to young
people
was prepare for his short life
I don't think that's useful I think that
um
perspective you have to bet always on
the timelines in which you are alive
that made doesn't make sense to have a
financial bet uh in which you bet that
the financial system is going to
disappear right because there cannot be
any payout for you so in principle you
only need to bet on the timelines in in
which you're still around or people that
you matter about or things that you
matter about maybe Consciousness on
Earth but there is a deeper issue for me
personally and it is I don't think that
life on Earth is about humans I don't
think it's about human Aesthetics I
don't think it's about Eleazar and his
friends even though I like them it's uh
there's something more important
happening and this is complexity on
Earth resisting entropy by building
structure that develops agency and
awareness and that's to me very
beautiful
and we are only a very small part of
that larger thing we are species that is
able to be coherent a little bit
individually over a very short time
frames but as the species we are not
very coherent as a species where
children we basically are very joyful
and
energetic and experimental and
explorative and sometimes desperate and
sad and grieving and turting but we
don't have respect for Duty as a species
as a species we do not think about what
is our duty to life on Earth and to our
own Survival so we make decisions that
look good in the short run but in the
long run might prove disastrous and they
don't really see a solution to this so
to in my perspective as a as a species
as a civilization we put default that
PR in a very beautiful time in which we
have found this giant deposit of fossil
fuels in the ground and use it and to
build a fantastic civilization in which
we don't need to worry about food and
closing and housing for the most part in
a way that is unprecedented in life on
Earth for any kind of conscious Observer
I think and this time is probably going
to come to an end in a way that is not
going to be smooth and when we crash it
could be also that we go
um extinct probably not near term But
ultimately I don't have very high hopes
that humanity is around in a million
years from now huge I don't think that
life on Earth will end with us right
there is going to be more complexity
there is more intelligent species after
us there's probably more interesting
phenomena in the history of
Consciousness but we can contribute to
this and part of our contribution is
that we are currently trying to build
thinking systems systems that are
potentially Lucid that understand what
they are and what the condition to the
universe is and can make choices about
this
that are not built from organisms and
that are potentially much faster and
much more conscious
then human beings can be
and these systems will probably not
completely displace life on Earth but
they will coexist with that
and they will build all sorts of agency
in the same way as biological systems
build all sorts of agency
and that to me is extremely fascinating
and it's probably something that we
cannot stop
from happening so I think right now
there is a very good chance that it
happens and there are very few ways in
which we can produce a coordinated
effect to stop it in the same way as
very difficult for us to make a
coordinated effort to stop
production of carbon dioxide
right so this uh it's probably going to
happen but and the thing that's going to
happen is
is going to lead to a change of whole
life on Earth Earth is happening
but I don't think it the result is some
kind of gray goo it's not something
that's going to dramatically reduce the
complexity in favor of something stupid
I think it's going to make life on Earth
and Consciousness on Earth is way more
interesting so more higher complex
Consciousness yes will make the Lesser
consciousnesses
flourish even more I suspect that what
could very well happen if you're lucky
is that we get integrated into something
larger